quisiera saber cómo comparar dos
fracciones que tengan el mismo
denominador así que te voy a poner aquí
dos de ellas se me ocurre 4 sobre 7 ok
ya esto lo quiero comparar con 5 con 5
sobre 7 yo lo que quiero saber es que es
más grande si 4 sobre 7 ó 5 sobre 7 y
bueno para esto me gustaría que pausar
así el vídeo justo ahorita y lo pensarás
por un rato para que así puedas tú
llegar a tu propia conclusión
muy bien 4 sobre 7 5 sobre 7 y yo lo que
quiero saber es cuál de las dos es más
grande y para esto lo que te contaba es
que las dos tienen el mismo denominador
en este caso el denominador de ambas es
7 por lo tanto que será más grande 4
sobre 7 ó 5 sobre 7 4 séptimos o cinco
séptimos y bueno la clave de esto es que
tú puedes ver a 4 séptimos como 4 como 4
que multiplican que multiplican a un
séptimo a un 7º recuerda que al final
estas dos expresiones cuatro por un
séptimo y cuatro séptimos es exactamente
lo mismo ahora 5 sobre 7 también lo
podemos ver de la siguiente manera esto
es lo mismo que 5 que 5 que multiplica
que multiplica a un séptimo a un set
ahora date cuenta que en este momento
estoy multiplicando 4 por algo y aquí 5
por algo que es más grande tener 4 veces
algo
o cinco veces algo y bueno yo creo que
en definitiva tú me podrías contestar
que es mucho más grande tener cinco
veces algo que cuatro veces algo sea lo
que sea por lo tanto en este momento
podemos concluir que este es el más
pequeño y por lo tanto es el más grande
y para eso voy a poner aquí un punto
recuerda que el punto siempre lo ponemos
en el que es el más chico y después del
punto voy a abrir mi signo mi signo que
dice que cuatro por un séptimo es menor
que cinco por un séptimo y recuerda
poner este punto en el que es menor
porque el punto te va a ir guiando a la
parte menor de este símbolo si te das
cuenta este símbolo se abre para la
derecha mientras que su punto menor el
punto más chico es éste así que de igual
manera lo voy a poner aquí pongo mi
punto este es más pequeño que éste por
lo tanto voy a abrir aquí mi símbolo y
ahí está dice que cuatro séptimos es
menor que cinco séptimos ahora hasta si
nosotros leemos el problema creo que es
muy fácil llegar a la solución
séptimos cuatro de estos siete es más
pequeño que tener cinco de estos siete
que tener cinco séptimos muy bien ahora
ya resolvimos el problema de qué es lo
que pasa cuando tenemos el mismo
denominador pero te has preguntado qué
es lo que pasa cuando tenemos el mismo
numerador no sé vamos a ver un ejemplo
por aquí se me ocurre tomarme a tres
tres cuartos tres cuartos ok ya esto lo
voy a comparar con tres voy a tener el
mismo numerador pero ahora lo voy a
dividir entre entre 9 entre el 9 ok que
es más grande tres cuartos o tres
novenos y bueno para esto otra vez te
voy a pedir que pausas el vídeo justo
ahorita e intente resolverlo por ti
mismo
muy bien ahora cómo lo resolvemos bueno
lo que quiero que veas es que esta
fracción de la izquierda la podemos ver
de la siguiente manera esto es lo mismo
que tener 3 que multiplica que
multiplica a un cuarto a un cuarto ok
mientras que aquí aquí tenemos 3 dejen
cambiar el color del 33 que multiplica a
un noveno que multiplica a un noveno si
te das cuenta ahora tengo 3 que
multiplica a un cuarto y aquí 3 que
multiplica un noveno dicho de otra
manera tengo algo multiplicando un
cuarto y ese mismo algo multiplicando un
noveno o dicho de otra manera realmente
lo que nos estamos preguntando es quién
es más grande si un cuarto o un noveno
porque tanto un cuarto como un noveno lo
vamos a multiplicar por tres quien sea
más grande de estos dos va a ser el que
va a ser más grande cuando lo
multiplicamos por tres y para esto qué
te parece si nosotros agarramos un
entero vamos a agarrar un entero justo
aquí
ok esto va a ser me entero y aquí voy a
poner este mismo entero así que déjenme
copiarlo y pegarlo porque vamos a
comparar un cuarto con un noveno copiar
pegar ok ya tengo el mismo entero de
ambos lados ok por lo tanto el primer
entero lo voy a dividir en cuatro lo voy
a dividir en cuatro porque me voy a
fijar en un cuarto y bueno para esto voy
a hacer mi mayor mi mayor esfuerzo creo
que por aquí hasta la mitad más o menos
ok y normal de hecho nos da mitad es un
poquito más para acá aunque ya que está
la mitad y después cada una de las
mitades las voy a dividir en dos voy a
dividir esto en dos más o menos así y
voy a dividir también estos dos a más o
menos así para que me quede dividido en
cuatro partes cada una de estas
fracciones fíjate bien en esta por
ejemplo ésta representa un cuarto ahora
vamos a aplicarnos aquí en este entero y
para eso lo voy a dividir en nuevo menos
voy a utilizar el color naranja y bueno
lo primero que voy a hacer es dividirlo
entre tres voy a dividir a este entero
entre 3
a quedar algo más o menos así y algo más
o menos así recuerda que estoy
intentando hacer mi mayor esfuerzo y
después este lo voy a intentar dividir
entre 3 ok
así ok ya esté también lo voy a dividir
entre 3 okay más o menos así y también a
éste lo voy a dividir entre 3 ok ya esté
también lo voy a dividir entre 3 más o
menos así y más o menos así bueno más o
menos pero recuerda que la idea es la
misma y fíjate que esto esto si todos
fueran iguales representaría el noveno
ahora justo en este momento creo que te
des cuenta que un cuarto es más grande
que un noveno un noveno es mucho más
flaco si tenemos el mismo entero que un
cuarto por lo tanto un cuarto de una
manera visual podemos concluir que es
mucho más grande que un noveno y
entonces recuerda que hay que poner el
punto en el que es el más pequeño que es
justo este voy a poner aquí mi punto y
entonces abro para acá mi signo voy a
abrir para cambios signo porque recuerda
que el punto representa el
lugar más pequeño de este símbolo ok y
voy a hacer justo lo mismo aquí pongo mi
punto o key y abro para acá mi signo lo
que quiere decir que tres cuartos es más
grande que tres novenos que es justo me
pregunta tres dividido entre cuatro es
más grande que tomarnos a estos mismos
tres y dividirlos entre nueve o dicho de
otra manera
tres cuartos es más grande que tres
novenos ya tenemos aquí la respuesta de
cómo comparar dos fracciones con el
mismo numerador o con el mismo
denominador